hello and welcome to another exciting
episode of the movieclips monday morning
review I'm Ryan I'm David I'm jail and
we're reviewing the lego movie today
guys it was excellent it was I mean I'm
I'm not gonna very late it was amazing i
love ya is it a cliche to say everything
is awesome about the lego movie i mean
i'd lean highbrow critics from like the
New York Times say that so I'll so I'll
be one to say it as well the hybrid
critic um just there's not really
spoilers plot wise to this movie but if
you're trying to keep all the cameos
secret and like what kind of characters
pop up we are going to be revealing some
of those things yet um should we say our
favorites well let's first just kind of
go go through why we like the movie so
much I thought that this movie mixed um
excitement in terms of like actual a
cartoony action it is legitimately funny
it's not just like kid funny it's funny
from the first line yeah everyone like
all the people in the theater both kids
and adults were laughing yeah and it's
actually very poignant and its message
is simple and very like nice it's not
trying to do too much with its message
but I really like what it was going and
just from a screenwriting standpoint
this film is brilliant it takes the
hero's journey in fact film critic who
I'm
phantom he's probably gonna be writing
an entire book about this movie when I
first tried there's gonna be a lego
movie I would kept thinking how is that
gonna work and then to see this and to
see how they all look they go to all the
different lands like that was just so
well done if like not to say something
so pompous is what I'm about to say it
this might be like the first postmodern
children's movie where it's like so
aware of itself it's very aware of what
it is but at the same time is so is
really sincere it doesn't feel like a
commercial it couldn't feel less like a
commercial what were your favorite
character yeah um this is a really
interesting version of that net and some
people have said it's the best on-screen
Batman we've ever had anything that
might very well be pitching yeah it's
hard to argue there's a scene where
Batman plays a song he wrote uh yeah
that was is one of the funniest things
I've ever yeah I was having trouble
breathing the Star Wars cambia the same
there's a there's a moment with the
Millennium Falcon that references a
specific moment in Star Wars that was
beyond really also there's a character
that's a good cop and a bad cough cough
embodied in the same lego figurine and
his head turns around I thought that
yeah I'm you said like and the way that
they start hinting at what eventually
becomes I'm not going to call it a twist
but a big reveal at the end the way they
set it up with with putting certain
brands in and like real life um kind of
objects really slowly eases us into that
so that when it actually happens we're
not completely shocked it doesn't take
you out of it in an insane of the voice
work is really really incredible Chris
Pratt who plays emmett the main
character um it's interesting because
you never quite stop thinking of Chris
Pratt being playing the character but
you're also not picturing him in a sound
booth he really embodies that character
and Will Ferrell as the kind of bad guy
board business and the animation style
it's from what I know aside from from
some very small inserts this was all
shot or all animated in using computers
sure see chief but it looks so much like
stop motion and looks so lifelike that
that illusion never really breasts it's
clearly the animators had rules that
they set them so and all of those
threats and the behind the scenes they
said that they actually put Legos under
microscopes to see what kind of material
they look like you can even see thumb
prints on some of the Legos in the
animation yeah and the way that it's
shot I mean the cinematography of the
whole thing that they made it seem like
real cameras we're shooting them almost
these like micro focus cameras so there
are times where just part of the
characters faces in focus and there's
even times where it looks like they kind
of act like put it into soft focus to
make it see how the cameraman messed up
um which is just amazing touches to kind
of sell the whole
and going along with that there's these
long takes long fakes that they have
where I'm one memorable one is when they
first enter the saloon and the camera
just whips around and we're seeing all
this chaos ensuing but it's it's all
done as if it is one camera shot and
everything because it's Lego bricks they
break and make themselves realistically
house they would if it really was so
much yeah it's it's gonna be the kind of
thing that you could probably go by go
through it on the blu-ray wait frame by
frame yeah and it always works out
should we talk a little bit about the
reveal that happens sure yeah movie um
one of the big reveals is that okay
these are actual Legos and a basement
and when the humans come down and
actually start interacting with the
characters I mean that really triggers I
hope ya like the the little kid looks
just kind of like the director and he
has the exact like basically he's the oh
the surrogate for the audience of like
this is the kid and this is sort of the
story that he's created yeah and also
what's what's cool about it though
there's a moment where Emmet is in the
real world but also manages to move
himself so they never break the magic of
like these Legos actually or animate
objects who have thoughts and monsey our
own um it's not just like oh we've been
watching this all in the imagination of
a child like he created the world but
they maintain that like to know this is
really happening like there's emotional
stakes they somehow don't sacrifice the
emotional state of it when they do that
yeah we've never really seen that in a
movie before the lego movie is amazing
go see it I can't even I can't recommend
this movie enough and it sounds like a
lot of you already did I mean I think I
broke records for every so much money
yeah and like that guarantees a sequel
which I already started writing it
before this one even yeah so I mean I I
can't wait for that it's gonna be a
great year for animated movies it's a
wonderful wonderful way to start um it
let us know what you thought at the lego
movie unless you didn't like it
no but until next time I'm right I'm
David I'm Jess thanks for watching